okay so here we go
i'm pleased to present the bronze medal
honors to director maro mueller for his
film unmundo para rule
tomorrow we learned today at the
cinematographer association that if you
put the light right on bronze looks like
gold so that's what it is for me
first of all i want to thank the academy
rich miller john farr
the board of governors all the members
and the staff i had an incredible week
it was a true true honor to be to meet
so many accomplished filmmakers and they
shared stories they shared and they were
very generous with their time
and
um yeah i'm very grateful for this
awesome week
um
we were driven around we were put up in
a really nice hotel we went to spargo so
they tried all the tricks they had to
bring me from new york to l.a
i believe the film is an international
collaboration i'm from switzerland my
wife is from mexico but i made the film
at columbia university and i'm adapted
to the
university and to all the mentors to all
the professors i had
i really
felt that i got all the tools i need to
now um do this transition into um
professional filmmaking
i want to mention
in particular two professors julia
solomonov and henry bean who were
essential in creating the story and
story always comes first so that was one
of the main parts that we learned in
colombia
i want to thank the two actors
adrian and alex
it's a difficult topic matter and did an
incredible job
the one thing i really had to do is to
step back and just let them do their job
and i want to thank the other actors
gerardo roberto and adriana thanks and i
hope we'll be working again
together um
i want to thank my producer my mexican
producer laura pino um
thanks for you were one of the first
person to come on board i really
appreciate that
um you also helped me assemble the team
the great cinematographer cesar
gutierrez um
rodrigo plato and emmanuel betsky really
have to watch out because the next
mexican cinematographer is coming
um
i want to thank my composer lukasz
for this for the amazing music um my
producing partners from fidelio mark
maurice and david you're the backbone of
each project we're doing
my swiss producers iwan and urs
it's unusual for swiss filmmaker to make
projects internationally um you believed
in me and i'm really thankful for that
last but not least i want to thank my
family in switzerland and mexico and my
wife for being with me for seven years
i don't know how you can do it but i'm
really thankful
and thanks again to the academy for
allowing me to show the phone to you
it's an important topic matter the
social differences
that not only exist in mexico but also
in the us so thank you so much